[Music]
hey you get over here
oh i know what it is you're afraid
because i'm the big bad wolf the villain
of every story
and this is the crew mr angela mr shark
mr piranha mr snake everyone copy copy
copy
we're the bad guys it's crime time baby
shark we need a distraction do you like
it
fine please be subtle i'm having a baby
is there a doctor or perhaps several
security guards that could leave that
post and help me
we were never given a chance to be
anything more than criminals but these
are the cars we've been dealt so we
might as well play them
here let me help you are you okay ma'am
thank you dear you're such a good boy
wait what i'm the bad
guy
all good brother oh good yeah yeah
you ever wonder what it'd be like if the
world wasn't scared of us never gonna
happen guys we're gonna go good
did you get hit on the head he villains
have an image problem you need a
makeover
so
no well there goes our street cred
well i'm tired of being an outcast maybe
i don't want to be a what a bad guy
you're going to have to choose between
your friends or the good life they're
the only friends i've ever had you have
a chance to write your own story what
have you got salute i don't know my
dignity yeah well that ship has already
sailed so you're a tough guy
that is an animal testing man with
helpless guinea pigs i'll rescue them
you've never volunteered for anything
oh come on snake open up relax these
doors are complicated
are you kidding me we're supposed to
save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
outside
[Music]
[Music]
foreign